moi c'est un âge je suis à sexuelle
aujourd'hui j'aimerais répondre aux
questions qu'on me pose souvent sur tik
tok
à propos de la sexualité la sexualité
c'est quoi la sexualité est une
orientation sexuelle au même titre que
les autres êtres à sexuelle c'est notre
attiré par personne
c'est tout aussi légitime en tant
qu'organisation et du coup tu as une vie
sexuelle
ça va vraiment dépendre des asexuels
certains vont être trop fonder mans
repoussé par les organes génitaux par
l'idée d'avoir un rapport sexuel
d'autres en auront rien à faire seront
ce qu'on appelle lé sexe indifférent et
d'autres y seront plutôt favorable et
apprécieront le fait de faire
fonctionner leurs corps de passer un bon
moment avec quelqu'un d'avoir des
rapports pour le fun pour le plaisir
physique est globalement plus
mécaniquement bas il ya des asexuels
dont le corps peut ressentir des
orgasmes du plaisir physique via les
organes génitaux et d'autres pas du tout
qui ne ressentiront rien fait le corps
peut tout à fait répondre aux stimuli
qu'on lui donne par le toucher par la
caresse et de ce fait ce plaisir là peut
être appréciable
ou pas c'est un choix est transsexuel ce
n'est ni un choix une une phase au même
titre que quelqu'un d'homosexuels ne
choisit pas d'être homo banon ne
choisissons pas non plus d'être à
sexuelle
on peut quand même être amoureux il faut
bien différencier la sexualité de la
romantisme arme anti c'est la même chose
mais quand on ne ressent pas d'attirance
amoureuse nous les asexuels purement à
sexuelle on peut ressentir de
l'attirance amoureuse est donc tombé
amoureux c'est difficile à assumer
être à sexuelle et grandiose dans une
société qui est by ultra sexuelle et en
plus de ça hétéronormée ça peut créer
énormément de mahler énormément de
douleurs psychologiques comme physique
parce que une personne à sexuelle en
grandissant on va être entouré de
personnes qui vont lui raconter leurs
expériences et du coup forcément on va
se demander pourquoi est-ce que lui il
n'en a pas et comme ça a pu m'arriver on
peut se retrouver à avoir des rapports
pour ressembler aux autres sous la
pression ou simplement se disant bas ce
que je ressens en fait c'est pas normal
donc pourquoi est ce qu'il faudrait pas
juste que je saute à l'eau ça sert à
quoi de se définir à sexuelle il est
important de mettre des mots non pas
pour différencier les gens non pas pour
se mettre dans des cases mais simplement
pour se soulager
pour se dire ce que je suis porte un nom
donc ce que je suis et légitime
j'ai le droit d'être comme je le suis ce
n'est pas une maladie ce n'est je n'ai
pas en guérir je peux être heureux comme
ça et surtout avant toute chose je ne
suis pas seul parce que mettre des mots
c'est créer des communautés c'est créer
des échanges entre les gens la première
fois où j'ai lu le mot à sexualité je me
souviens que deere je me sentais pas du
tout concerné parce que du coup j'avais
des rapports même si c'était un rapport
un peu bizarre et le jour où je me suis
dit ok en fait je suis à sexuelle ça m'a
enlevé un poids énorme parce que je me
suis dit j'ai plus besoin de chercher à
avoir du désir j'ai plus besoin à adé
d'aller chercher des thérapeutes qui
pourront me guérir parce qu'en fait ce
n'est pas guérissable et ça na pas être
guéri et maman que je le sais mais je
peux profiter de ce que je suis de ce
que j'aime je peux maintenant je sais
mieux ce que je n'aime pas
on peut avoir des enfants je pense que
c'est la question qu'on nous pose le
plus au sein de nos familles oui un
asexuels pas avoir d enfant s'il en a
envie évidemment puisque avoir des
enfants je crois pas que ça ait grand
chose à voir avec avoir du désir sexuel
en réalité en faveur des enfants parce
qu'on a envie de fonder une famille
parce que c'est quelque chose qui nous
importe les sexes reapers quant à eux
évidemment ne pourront pas forcément
concevoir physiquement des enfants se
reproduire si on peut dire ça comme ça
puisque le fait d'avoir un rapport
sexuel les repousse mais après pouvons
tout à fait utiliser la pma ou
l'adoption ou voilà en fait je pense
qu'il est aujourd'hui très important de
montrer que d'autres chemins sont
possibles et qu'on peut tout à fait être
heureux sans avoir de désir et qu'on
peut avoir ce ne pas avoir d dire mais
avoir des relations ou pas est tout
simplement fait que cela ne regarde que
vous